des grands temps de ce télétransporter
dans la bibliothèque de vous êtes
formidables on va les retrouver Tiphaine
feiffer qui va nous être du baume au
coeur aujourd'hui ça ça fait plaisir
avec des livres pour enfants sur le
thème de la guérison alors c'est pas
vraiment triste mais c'est d'une grande
sensibilité quand même Tiphaine j'ai
l'impression oui Pascal et le premier
livre que j'ai apporté et bien vous
donne tout de suite le ton puisqu'il
s'appelle cui-cui le petit chien
d'Antonin Louchard il s'est publié au
Seuil jeunesse alors vous le voyez le
titre est plutôt amusant et en fait il
parle d'un petit chien qui a un énorme
problème c'est un chien de garde mais il
n'arrive pas à effrayer les passants
pour protéger sa maison puisqu'à chaque
fois qu'il veut aboyer le seul petit
bruit qui sort de sa gueule c'est cuit
cuit donc vous le voyez c'est quand même
un peu gênant alors c'est mettre des
sites de l'emmener chez l'orthophoniste
et là incroyable lui qui pensait être
seul se retrouve face à une dizaine
d'animaux qui ont le même problème que
lui alors imaginez un chat qui concerne
ou une oie qui miaule et vous le voyez
la salle d'attente est surpeuplée
finalement en quelques séances le
problème est réglé et ce joli petit
livre qui paraissait comme ça à nos
dents permet en fait de parler en creux
de tous ces petites maladies tous ces
handicaps que peuvent avoir les enfants
et puis et bien c'est assez rassurant
pour un enfant de 3 ans de se rendre
compte qu'il n'est pas seul et que
finalement en demandant de l'aide on
peut résoudre ces problèmes et on peut
en rire alors je vous le recommande
Antonin Louchard et bien c'est un auteur
jeunesse très très réputé et à chaque
livre et bien on a une excellente
surprise donc n'hésitez pas à le mettre
entre les mains de tous les enfants à
partir de 2-3 ans cuit le petit chien
d'Antonin Louchard j'en connais un qui a
des chiens qui sont un peu plus costauds
Jérémy et qui ce week-end va défendre la
cause animale parce qu'il va se passer
quelque chose à Dole il y a un salon du
chiot qui se tient à Dole les salons du
chiot sont réputés pour être un
mercantile et faire venir des animaux un
petit peu de partout de toute la France
et donc l'association canine
territoriale a décidé de manifester son
mécontentements dès samedi à 13h30
devant l'expo mais aussi le dimanche
pour remettre en fait la question du
bien-être animal et du bien-être canin
au centre des réflexions donc voilà
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui auquel
il faut participer allez nous on va
parler du bien-être de nos enfants avec
le rayon lecture et Tiphaine et votre
deuxième coup de cœur cette fois c'est
une maman qui a le Blue c'est ça ou
c'est son héros qu'elle blouse j'ai pas
tout compris dans votre dans votre
ouvrage
ça s'appelle le petit cafard de maman de
John lavonia et Sophie Jackson publié à
l'étagère du bas et ça parle du
bien-être vous avez raison Pascal parce
que qu'est-ce que c'est que ce petit
cafard et bien figurez-vous que le héros
n'en sait rien on lui a seulement dit
que sa maman était fatiguée qu'il
fallait être sage à cause d'un petit
alors vous le voyez son imagination
s'emballe et ne sait pas quoi penser il
s'est juste et bien que le cafard c'est
un insecte alors il décide et bien
d'imaginer un autocollant un piège
autocollant géant une sorte et bien de
de déguisement pour l'attraper et même
d'adopter un prédateur un chat qui
pourrait se débarrasser de ce cafard
alors vous le voyez cet album aurait pu
être très triste puisque finalement le
cafard de sa maman vous l'imaginez bien
c'est la dépression mais on trouve en
fait des dessins assez gai une manière
jolie de parler de ce problème et je
vous le conseille pour les enfants à
partir de 5 ans dans les familles où on
pourrait croiser ce problème puisque et
bien c'est une jolie manière de parler
de ce souci qui touche finalement plus
de famille que ce qu'on pourrait croire
et qui est adapter aux jeunes enfants
mais nous on aime pendant que vous allez
chasser non pas le cafard mais le chaque
vous avez dans la gorge Tiphaine je me
tourne vers vous Elodie vous vous êtes
la maman de Marie 7 ans qui est en CE1
vous vous la faites lire ou la bloquez
sur la tablette non non elle adore bon
elle regarde aussi un petit peu la
tablette il faut l'avouer mais elle
adore lire en ce moment elle est sur la
série Mortal Adèle qu'elle voilà quelle
date elle adore et elle dévore donc donc
je retiens les deux titres ça devrait
lui plaire aussi bon puis comme on dit
jamais deux sans trois c'est une autre
maman qui était avec nous c'est la maman
d'Eric et de Suzanne Tiphaine qui est là
on peut pas on peut pas se quitter ça
sur le troisième livre forcément et ce
troisième livre parle de sujet sérieux
comment on le fait souvent mais avec
tact quand même ça nous arrive assez
souvent dans cette chronique et cette
fois la tristesse n'est pas causée par
une maladie mais plutôt par
malheureusement le spectacle de la
misère oui tout à fait ce livre sans
détour et écrit par deux auteurs que
j'aime beaucoup Pascal c'est pour ça que
je voulais vous en parler Stéphanie de
maspotier est Tom hogomat c'est publié
aussi à l'étagère du bas et ça parle
d'une petite fille qui tous les matins
en allant à l'école croise une maman et
son bébé sur le trottoir et oui donc ce
livre parle des SDF et cette petite
fille est complètement désemparée elle
ne comprend pas pourquoi elle ne peut
pas ramener cette famille à la maison
pourquoi sa maman ne fait rien et
pourquoi cette situation existe et
finalement ce livre et bien parle d'une
d'un sentiment que l'on peut ressentir
nous aussi quand on est et bien devant
notre café chaud à la maison et cette
petite fille dit mais qu'est-ce que je
pourrais bien faire pour aider et bien
un de ses enfants comme il en existe
finalement 42000 en France oui 42000
vous vous rendez compte Pascal et ce
livre et bien se met à hauteur d'enfants
et sa maman trouve une consolation lui
dit et bien peut-être que tu pourrais
faire un geste qui est à t'apporter
peut-être partager un moment un jouet un
regard avec ses enfants alors je vous
conseille ce livre puisque finalement
quand on a des enfants on se rend compte
que souvent ils sont très touchés par
cette situation qui nous en parle et
qu'on est assez démuni ce livre
s'appelle sans détour c'est très joli
vraiment je vous le conseille et puis
nous Pascal on aime partager donc voilà
je voulais partager décidé de lecture
avec vous
on a une solution pour apaiser la
tristesse et retrouver le sourire c'est
c'est partager un sourire on peut se
faire un sourire faites-moi un sourire
comme tous les jours dans cette émission
mais voilà exactement ce gentil un joli
sourire on en a besoin dans ce monde
troublé je le disais vous êtes
formidable merci Tiphaine la sélection
livre de la région et d'ailleurs à
retrouver aussi sur le net et les
réseaux sociaux vous embrassez Eric et
Suzanne et à une prochaine fois Tiphaine
pour de nouvelles aventures avec plaisir